this is this is definitely a difficult
Choice yeah you know would you one of
the things that the left has done over
the last couple years has made it seem
like it's always the people on the right
that are coming after your Free Speech
but if we've learned anything it's that
the left and the wokers and all of the
big tech people those are the ones the
Democrats the lefties who are actually
coming for your free speech take a look
the Democrats appear to be more Pro
censorship than the Republicans um and
used to be the opposite it used to be
you know the left position was freedom
of speech um you know uh I believe at
one point um the ACLU even def defended
the right of someone to claim that they
were Nazi or something like that you
know so like there were there really
were uh like the left was freedom of
speech is is is fundamental um and I
mean my at Le perception Perhaps it is
inaccurate is that um
the pro censorship is more on the left
than than the right I really can't get
over this thing about the way he speaks
and how he's giving the other side every
benefit of the to my perception maybe
it's not correct no your perception is
correct and actually the first time that
I met with Elon at Twitter in San
Francisco we talked about a few things
about my account and that sort of stuff
but the part where he was most engaged
in the conversation like locked in bang
like that was when we started talking
about oh I me was one of the people that
like left the left publicly and why I
left the left and I didn't leave
liberalism liberalism left me and he
posted a meme eventually showing how he
stayed the same but it's the left that
went bananas he he fully gets it the
same way you get it he gets it and you
can see the way he is being treated by
the system I just want to show you one
more clip of the interview because then
uh sorin basically asked him who he
would vote for and I think this was sort
of
interesting I would not vote for Biden
you'd vote for Trump I'm not saying I
vote for Trump but I
mean this is this is definitely a
difficult Choice yeah you know would you
would you vote for Nikki Haley Nikki
Haley by the way wants uh all social
media
um names to be exposed as you know no I
think that's outrageous yeah no I'm not
going to vote for some Pro censorship
cand right I'll do them backwards so the
Nikki Haley one with him um it's it's
like a complete deal breaker right
you're not going to tell a guy who
bought a giant tech company purging
money that they can't have Anonymous
users there are issues with Anonymous
users there's issu issues with trolls
and Bots and all that stuff he's done a
lot with Bots to eliminate Bots by the
way um but it's getting harder and
harder because AI is getting smarter so
bots in the old day would old days would
just have copy and paste comments and
computers were just you know tweeting
things out repetitively Bots are getting
much smarter they can put your name in
it they can change the language but he
has done more about that but obviously
he's not going to vote for Nikki Haley
like the very idea of that one is just
okay so that one's out of the way uh
then he said uh Trump he's not
sure I my suspicion is he if it ends up
being Biden or Trump and he's brave
enough to say who he will vote for I
think he would vote for Trump but him
being so sort of hands off on on whether
he could support Trump or not I think
shows you the bigger problem with Trump
in general that all of these people who
have so had it with the Democrats
they're is still a mass aversion to
Trump and you may not agree with that
mass aversion and you might think it's
misguided or whatever but it is
real